Many reactions of alkynes are similar to those
of alkenes, so I recommend watching our alkene
video first.
Let’s begin with a few alkyne-forming reactions.
The first method we’ll examine is a multistep
process called the Corey–Fuchs reaction.
An aldehyde is treated with a mixture of carbon
tetrabromide and triphenylphosphene.
CBr4 reacts with triphenylphosphene to form
this organophosphorous compound, or Wittig
reagent, which reacts with the aldehyde to
form a dibromoalkene.
The bromide is subsequently treated with the
strong base n-butyllithium to cause an elimination
reaction, forming the alkyne after treatment
with water.
Dihalides, which may be formed by halogenation
of alkenes, can be treated with two equivalents
of the strong base, sodium amide, to form
internal alkynes.
This process can also be used to form terminal
alkynes; however, three equivalents of the
strong base are required.
Let’s examine why by looking at the mechanism.
The first molar equivalent of sodium amide
deprotonates the molecule and causes elimination
of bromine, forming an intermediate alkene.
The second equivalent repeats this process,
creating the alkyne.
Terminal alkynes have a pKa of about 24, which
makes them acidic enough to be deprotonated
by sodium amide.
The third equivalent deprotonates the terminal
H atom, creating an anion, which is why water
is needed in both of the reactions that form
terminal alkynes.
The fact that alkynes can be deprotonated
with strong base leads us to our first reaction
of alkynes.
A deprotonated alkyne, or acetylide anion,
can be alkylated with a primary alkyl halide.
It is important that the alkyl halide is primary.
The acetylide ion is a strong base, so it
can cause elimination if reacted with hindered
alkyl halides.
Alkynes can be reduced completely by hydrogenation,
forming alkanes.
When a palladium catalyst treated with lead
salts, called Lindlar’s catalyst, is used
in alkyne hydrogenation, the alkyne may be
reduced to the Z-alkene.
The E- alkene can be formed by treating the
alkyne with sodium in liquid ammonia.
This is a radical reaction; sodium transfers
a single electron to the alkyne, forming a
radical anion.
This anion adopts the more stable conformation,
putting the methyl groups on opposite sides
of a double bond before it is protonated by
ammonia.
The mechanism here is abbreviated, but sodium
donates another electron, forming a new anion,
which is again protonated by ammonia.
Like alkenes, alkynes can add halogens across
multiple bonds.
Bromination or chlorination gives the tetrahalide;
here, addition of Br2 across the bond occurs
via a bromonium ion.
Halides can also be added using hydrobromic
or hydrochloric acid.
Note the regioselectivity; two equivalents
of the halide are added to the more substituted
side of the alkyne.
We see Markovnikov addition; the proton adds
to the less substituted carbon to form the
more stable carbocation, and the addition
occurs again in the same way to the intermediate
chloroalkene.
Terminal alkynes can be converted to aldehydes
or ketones selectively with appropriate reagent
choice.
Hydroboration/oxidation, a two-stage process
where the alkyne is first treated with a boron
reagent, then oxidized, produces an aldehyde.
The boron reagent adds to the least hindered
side—the terminus of the alkyne.
The large boron reagent prevents attack on
the intermediate, and the oxidation step gives
an enol, which tautomerizes to the more stable
ketone.
Oxymercuration can be used to produce ketones
directly from alkynes.
The alkyne reacts to form a mercurinium ion.
Water then attacks at the more substituted
carbon atom, since the mercurinium ion has
carbocation resonance, and the secondary carbocation
contributes more to the overall structure
than the primary carbocation.
Again, the enol tautomerizes to the ketone,
and sulfuric acid protonates the carbonyl.
This promotes elimination of mercury forming
another enol, and a final tautomerization
gives the ketone.